well thanks for being here folks thanks
for listening and glad to be back at the
home base I've been traveling doing a
lot of traveling the last last couple
weeks actually I'll be on the road again
next week because I'm going to speak at
the University of wisconsin-milwaukee so
if you are in the area there come on out
and and and and come and take part in
that conversation but anyway traveling
and I'm not a big fan of traveling
especially on airplanes I do it all the
time but I'm a very anxious flier I must
admit and it was especially bad on the
way home one of the legs of a flight
that I was taking I'm boarding the plane
captain comes on the you know the
intercom and this is the word he used he
said we're expecting a pretty bumpy
flight it's gonna be unpleasant he used
the word unpleasant now if you do a lot
of flying you know that that pilots of
commercial aircraft are notorious for
understating things so you could hit
turbulence and plunge 10,000 feet right
into the Atlantic Ocean and they would
just come on and say well sorry for that
little bump there folks and so now I me
think about Sully the captain Sully with
the miracle on the Hudson if you've ever
seen any interviews of that he did where
he described what happened now he's
talking about engine goes out plane is
about to explode maybe I might I might
have made that part up but and he has to
land his his plane in the river but the
way he describes it his mannerisms and
the language he's using it makes it
sound like he's describing a trip to the
DMV so these are very calm and collected
people you have to be for that job they
don't overstate things ever so he's
saying unpleasant I am translating that
as we are definitely all going to die
although we didn't thankfully and it was
almost as bad as the time a couple years
ago I was flying and I was actually
sitting next to a pilot who I guess he
was taking this plane to get to a
different airports that he could then
fly a plane because if you're a pilot
for a commercial airline and you have to
fly as a passenger they put you in coach
he was actually sitting in the middle
seat of coach at all the way towards the
back of the plane they can't even give
him comfort plus I mean this guy's a
pilot anyway sitting next to him we hit
turd
he's not reacting which is what you want
to see but at one point we had we hit a
really bad bump and he goes he turns
looks out the window and goes whoa just
like that that's all he said but I know
I'm turning to him and saying would you
would you say whoa for what's what's the
whole about we're gonna die now is this
what you're saying
whoa cuz we're gonna die is that what
you're saying anyway but all it all
turned out okay
so a lot to talk about today let's start
with this another Democrat is being
investigated for having a sexual
relationship with a staffer this one is
Alcee Hastings Democrat congressman from
Florida he's apparently had a long-term
sexual relation with a woman on his
staff by the way he's 83 years old and
Hastings is this the same guy accused of
sexual harassment by another former
staffer and the Treasury the Treasury ie
translated as the taxpayers paid out
almost quarter of a million dollars to
settle that case but here's the thing I
just because this is in the news I what
a quick fun some fun facts about this
Hastings character he was a circuit
court judge back in the 1970s nominated
by Carter well shortly after taking the
job I think it was nominated in 78
whereabouts and then in like 80 or 81 he
was charged criminally with accepting
bribes and with perjury allegedly he
accepted $150,000 bribe in order to give
someone a lenient sentence so I mean
this is just grade-a corruption that's
that's about as corrupt as a judge can
get when you're accepting money in
exchange for lenient sentences he wasn't
convicted because his co-conspirator
refused to testify against him but he
was did was impeached and removed from
office by the Senate he's one of only a
handful of judges ever to be removed
from the Senate oh and the
co-conspirator by the way he refused to
testify again good friend at least
refused to testify again at the
impeachment hearings and then he went to
jail again
and then he was pardoned by Bill Clinton
on Clinton's last day in office by the
time the Clinton pardoned Hastings
co-conspirator Hastings was a member of
Congress
a member of the same body that impeached
him for being corrupt and while he's
been in Congress he's behaved exactly as
he would expect someone like this to
behave having unethical sexual
relationships getting sued for
harassment leasing luxury vehicles with
tax money hiring his friends and
relatives and nepotism all over the
place so my point is when we talk about
the swamp this is exactly the kind of
crap we're referring to Hastings has
been in Kies eighty three-years-old
been in Congress for thirty years and he
only went to run for Congress as a
back-up plan after he was too corrupt to
be a judge so you're too corrupt to be a
judge in America well then what's the
back-up plan well you might as well
become a congressman so he's a crook
he's a fraud and he's a charlatan and
he's well known as such but he's been in
Congress of 30 years in conclusion the
people down in Florida who keep voting
this crook into office our absolute
buffoons so nice job to all you folks
down to Florida who are voting for this
guy because there's really I guess
there's just nobody there's no one else
I guess right is it no no one else you
could possibly imagine electing for the
job speaking of the swamp Democrat
representative Rashid it's Lieb ranking
member of the squad probably the Lance
Bass of the group definitely not last in
importance but also definitely not first
so she sort of vying with Omar for
second fiddle to play second fiddle to a
o'seas Justin Timberlake anyway she's
now subject of a house ethics committee
investigation because of her repeated
request for money during her campaign to
be used on personal expenses now I guess
there's a version of doing this where it
would be legal and there's a version
where it's illegal and the lines kind of
murky because these people these people
in Congress they love murky lines when
it comes to their ethical behavior and
let ethical rules they want the lines to
be as vague as possible as reported by
The Daily wire a referral that the
committee received from the Office of
Congressional Ethics says quote
representative leaves campaign committee
wish Rasheeda to lead for Congress
reported campaign to
verse means that may not be legitimate
and verifiable campaign expenditures
attributable to bona fide campaign or
political purposes if represent have to
leave converted campaign funds from
Rasheeda to leave for Congress to
personal use or if representative to
leaves campaign committee expended funds
that were not attributable to tribute
about to bona fide campaign or political
purposes then representative leave may
have violated House Rules standards of
conduct and federal law they owe the OCE
recommended that till he be investigated
because there is substantial reason to
believe that representative leave
converted campaign funds from Rasheeda
to lead for Congress to personal use or
Rasheeda to leaves campaign committee
expend funds that were not attributable
to bona fide campaign or political
purposes
so she Dave's got all these messages
that she sent asking for money
desperately asking for money from her
own campaign one example of a message
says I am struggling financially right
now I am I am sinking this was sent at
April 4th 2018 so I was thinking the
campaign could loan me money but Ryan
said that the committee could actually
pay me I was thinking a one-time payment
of $5,000 I think over it said between
May and December she was paid but 45
grand or something like that a bunch of
other messages in that vein so this is
all something to keep in mind when these
people are parsing Trump's actions
demanding ethical purity from Trump
which I think we all admit they don't
he's this is not Donald Trump we would
not call an ethically pure politician by
any means but in listen I think ethical
behavior and from our lawmakers and
politicians to include the president is
obviously important you know we don't I
don't think we should give any of these
people a pass we're paying them they
represented us we give them a lot of
power it's their responsibility to treat
that power with the respect and
discipline and integrity and honesty
that it warrants and I say that to
everybody in power Republican or
Democrat I don't care it doesn't make a
difference to me but the problem is that
many of these people in Washington right
now are so dirty so corrupt so
personally dismissive of the rules of
ethics and even the rule of law that
very few of them are in a position to
accuse anyone else of wrongdoing you
just can't trust them when they say you
can't trust their motives and certainly
they they can't be trusted when they
make those accusations themselves so
that's just something as as the
Democrats continue to wag their fingers
at Donald Trump talked about all the
rules of ethics and the rule of law
being violated and so on and so forth
just keep in mind keep the keep this in
mind keep in mind who your who we're
getting this from and there's your
depressing note to start the day many
other things to talk about including a
potential criminal assault that took
place during an NFL game yesterday is it
was a criminal assault I mean can you
really charge people criminally for
things that happen on a football field
we'll talk about that but before we do a
quick word from ancestry DNA I think
knowing your own history your own
ancestry it isn't just a nice bit of
trivia to bring up at the Thanksgiving
table it is that also a great
conversation started but also more
importantly it gives you insight into
yourself it tells you about your own
story ancestry DNA doesn't just tell you
which countries you're from but also can
pinpoint the specific regions within
them giving you insightful Geographic
detail about your own history you can
trace the paths of your recent ancestors
and learn how and why your family move
from place to place around the country
around the world rather from discovering
origins and over 500 regions to the most
connections to living real relatives no
other
test deliver such a unique interactive
completely full experience only ancestry
DNA uses the world's largest family
history database to give a deeper and
more detailed DNA story the process of
absenting the packet in to get all this
information about yourself and your
history is very simple very easy I've
done it myself and now I'm you know
waiting to get the results back can't
wait for it's going to be very exciting
and if you want to try it you can also
save big on ancestry DNA with special
holiday pricing and spark those
meaningful conversations around the
holiday dinner table
give the gift that can unwrap their
history head to that my Europe URL is
ancestry.com slash mat to get your
ancestry DNA kit on sale today that's
ancestry.com slash mat alright so this
is the thing people are talking about
today Steelers Browns last night another
horrible Thursday Night Football game
not really the point but it was a
horrible game Browns won at 21 to 7 just
an ugly bad game which is the only way
that Brett the Browns can ever win a
game because they have been for decades
an ugly bad football team and an ugly
bad football organization just an
embarrassment to the league matched only
by the other Ohio team no offense to the
people in Ohio but your football teams
are terrible you if you're if you live
in Ohio you own two of the worst and
most dysfunctional and incompetent
professional sports teams in American
history and they're both in your state
that would be the Bengals and then also
the Jets would vie for the title of most
incompetent so out there in New Jersey
that's not really the point though the
point is this and this is what happened
at the end of the game I'm going to show
you the whole clip if you haven't seen
it yet watch this
[Applause]
now he tackled Rudolph Rudolph didn't
like the way that he was tackled
[Applause]
rips the helmet off Rudolph's head and
then eventually swings it and hits it in
the head
and then elegant Joby comes up and hits
Rudolph from behind
[Applause]
beyond whoa that's one of worst things
I've ever seen a professional sports
field you know Joe I have been involved
with these of them so that's that's
miles Garrett with the Browns there
Mason Rudolph is the Steelers
quarterback and that's Miles Garrett
ripping off Rudolph's helmet and
smacking him in the head with it he
ripped off his helmet and smack from the
head with it that's that's amazing
even more amazing are the Browns fans
who have been trying to justify this and
I've seen a lot of them defending
Garrett saying that Rudolph's started it
which even if he did start it and by the
way again if you're a Browns fan your
organization is an embarrassment to the
league it's one of the worst
professional sports organizations in the
history of this country it's maybe don't
add insult to injury by embarrassing
yourselves by trying to justify this and
I mean and I'm a football fan myself too
but then I I love the Ravens okay I'm a
big Ravens Homer but at a certain point
I mean it is they are just a football
team and the only reason you root for
them is because you happen to live there
and I admit that for myself as well so
it's sort of arbitrary you don't have to
sacrifice your dignity to defend
criminal assault just because the guy
who did it
where's the jersey that you like right
you don't you don't have to do that you
really don't so but it and it doesn't
even matter but but because it doesn't
come close to justify it matter who
instigated it doesn't come close to
justifying what Garrett did but it just
for the record Garrett also instigated
this you saw the whole play there the
Rudolph had thrown the ball and Garrett
continued dragging him to the ground a
couple of seconds after the ball left
his hands that is already roughing the
passer especially these days but really
at any point that would be roughing the
passer that's pretty egregious after the
quarterback throws the ball you're
supposed to stop trying to tackle him
Garrett kept dragging to the ground
that's what made Rudolph upset he starts
tugging at his helmet Rudolph tugs at
Garrett's helmet and then that's where
Garrett just goes ballistic loses his
mind rips Rudolph's helmet off and smack
with it now Rudolph got lucky here
because it was the bottom of his helmet
that made contact with his head but what
if the crown of his helmet had hit
Rudolph say in his temple that's brain
damage at a minimum I mean that could
actually kill you
Garrett could have ended a life last
night and also probably the NFL along
with it you're talking about a 6-foot
for 270 pound muscle bound NFL defensive
end swinging a hard object directly at
your unprotected head there is
definitely a very plausible scenario
where Rudolph is not up and walking
around today he got lucky so what should
happen to Garrett I mean obviously at a
minimum he's done for the year I think
the NFL should go beyond that and
suspend them until 2022 or yeah suspend
him for this year and next year you can
come back the season after that because
you just can't have this people people
are not watching the NFL for this
garbage this isn't what people want to
see I mean maybe in hockey part of the
reason people watch is for the fights
that's that's not why people watch
football people watch football for
football and this stuff after the
whistle I think that usually it's just
annoying and you're like guys guys just
act like adults here and let's get back
to the game but this goes beyond
annoying this is this is well it's some
people are saying it's potentially
criminal and it does it does raise a
question I mean obviously the the law is
not forever suspended just because you
happened to be on a football field it's
not like you walk into a football field
you're walking into some bubble where
the law no longer applies there are
things you could do potentially on a
football field that would be criminal
not just wouldn't just be illegal of
according to the NFL rulebook but
illegal according to the law does this
cross that line I would say I mean yes I
would say it does now yeah you could say
that well a lot of the things that
happen in the context of a football game
if you did them out on the street you'd
go to jail like for example you know if
you just ran up and tackled somebody on
the streets you're gonna go to jail
that's assault you do it at a football
game I mean it's part of the game that's
true
but that's the stuff that happens
between the whistles in that that is the
point of all of that is if you're on
offense you're trying to advance the
ball to the end zone and if you're on
defense you're trying to stop the other
team from advancing the ball and so
everything you do is in that vein now
sometimes people go too far that's where
they get penalties but something that
happens a totally apart from the games
got nothing to do with the game whistle
has already blown okay now I think
you're in the realm where what you do
could actually be criminal and I think
that yeah if you do something after the
whistle completely egregious has nothing
to do with the game and you do something
that could potentially give someone
brain damage or worse then yeah I don't
see why you shouldn't be criminally
charged
why if if Miles Garrett had waited until
after the game and come up to Rudolph in
the parking lot and smacked him in the
head with a hard object would anybody
dispute that he should be that he should
be prosecuted for that of course we
would all agree no one how how could you
possibly disagree right unless you're
just going to say that well he's an NFL
player so it's okay unless we're gonna
say that NFL players are totally exempt
from the law which often that's the way
it works out but that's not the way it
should be so if if that exact thing
would be
we would all agree should make him
subject for prosecution in the parking
lot then why wouldn't it on the football
field after the whistle blows yeah you
don't yeah you could talk about slippery
slope you don't you don't want to end up
in a situation obviously where after
every play you got to bring the lawyers
in to see who committed a crime clearly
that's not where we want to go that
would just destroy the game but you
could say okay it's illegal criminally
illegal to smack somebody in the head
with a hard object on a football field
you could say that without then
destroying the football itself because
all we're saying to the football players
is you know you get a lot of leeway
especially during especially between the
whistles just don't try to literally
kill somebody
if you do that then okay now the fact
that you're wearing an NFL jersey isn't
going to protect you okay do you want to
be depressed if so this next segment is
for you I thought maybe you were looking
forward to being depressed the Guardian
has a lengthy article today with this
headline says I wish I'd never been born
the rise of the anti-natal lists
adherents view life not as a gift in a
miracle but a harm and an imposition and
their notion that having children may be
a bad idea seems to be gaining
mainstream popularity continuing from
the article written by Rebecca to host
Dubrow and the Guardian says in February
a 27 year old Indian man named Rafael
Samuel announced plans for an unusual
lawsuit said he was going to sue his
parents for begetting him it was not our
decision to be born he told the BBC
human existence is totally pointless
Samuel recently told me over Skype from
Mumbai that his is a good life and he is
actually close to his parents his
complaint is more fundamental he
believes is wrong to bring new people
into the world without their consent he
wanted to sue his parents for a symbolic
amount of money such as a single rupee
to instill that fear among parents in
general because now parents don't think
before having a child samuel subscribes
to a philosophy called antinatalism the
basic tenant of antinatalism is simple
but for most of us profoundly
counterintuitive that life even under
the best circumstances is not a gift or
America
a harm and an imposition according to
this logic the question of whether to
have a child is not just a personal
choice but an ethical one and the
correct answer is always no continuing a
little bit later on in the article says
in 2006 the south african philosopher
david Benatar published a book which is
widely credited with introducing the
term antinatalism in better hat in
better never to have been born the harm
of coming into existence Benatar quotes
the Greek tragedy tragedy in Suffolk
Lee's better to have been born is best
but if we must see the light the next
best is quickly returning whence we came
and he also quotes the text of
Ecclesiastes which by the way
Ecclesiastes is not in anti-natal as
text let's be clear about that these
quotes suggests that the sentiments at
the heart of antinatalism has been
around for a very long time in modern
history another strain of thought
emerged warning against the dangers of
population growth and so there have been
people talking about that and anyway it
I mean it's depressing but I would not
going to read this entire article but to
see where the culture is headed and
where some people are headed
philosophically I think I would
recommend going to the Guardian and
reading this article now on one level it
seems that antinatalism is really just
depression self-loathing and nihilism
dressed up as a philosophy on another
though it seems that this this is really
the pro-abortion position taken to its
logical end and what I mean is
antinatalism rests on the claim the
assumption
the conviction that life has no inherent
meaning no inherent purpose no inherent
value I mean that's what they're saying
it's totally pointless that's what the
guy who filed a lawsuit said and that's
also really what the pro-abortion
position rests on too so all the clump
of cells stuff is about it's about
claiming that life has no inherent value
the value is not inherent now you could
try to invent some kind of value for
yourself some sort of purpose or point
but at bottom it really comes down to it
there is no objective point or purpose
that is that is what the pro-abortion
movement even if it doesn't explicitly
say it it's what it implicitly says and
in fact the pro-abortion movement needs
that to be the case in order for their
position to work they need it to be the
case that life has no inherent value now
what they will try to do is they'll try
to get away with something like well the
quote unquote fetus has no value but
certainly people who are born have all
the inherent value in the world but that
doesn't really work inhairent value
means existing in something as an
essential attribute something that is
that is that is essential to the very
nature if something is inherent to you
it is essential to your very nature in
other words it kind of gets down to the
very core of your being and if that's
the case that means
inherent value things that are inherent
they can't be gained they can't be lost
you don't develop them gradually they
just are so if we have inherent value
inherent objective value then we must
have had that value from the very moment
of our conception when I when I give
talks pro-life talks the way that I try
to illustrate it the illustration I
often use is okay think of yourself in
your current state as you are right now
and you would probably say of yourself
right now that you have inherent value
you have inherent dignity human rights
all that stuff great you know that's
what you would say about yourself right
now I assume unless you're anti-natal
list now rewind the clock back ten
minutes well you still had inherent
value ten minutes ago right you didn't
have any you don't have any less of it
then than you do now everything's the
same inherent human dignity and
everything okay now Ryan the clock back
ten years same story go back to when you
were 10 years old same story that was
you you had inherent value inherent
dignity go back to when you were
one-year-old still you still inherent
value inherent human dignity okay great
back to the moment that you emerged from
your mother's birth canal and stop the
tape right there
who is that well that's you you had
inherent value inherent dignity
now we're wind the clock another 10
seconds just 10 seconds 10 more seconds
back what happened in that time you
changed locations
yes but it's still you right 10 seconds
before you were born that was still you
and so whatever was inherently true of
you when you were born
must have been inherently true of that
person that existed 10 seconds before
birth and then you just keep going back
all the way to conception there is an
unbroken chain of unis connecting the
you of today to the you that was
conceived in your mother's womb whatever
is there for whatever is inherently true
of the you of today must be inherently
true of the you that was conceived in
the womb and so the only way to justify
abortion is to say that well we don't
really have inherent value because I I
can't have inherent value without the me
in the womb also having it and that's
why even if probe orts are not as direct
about it and they don't want to come out
and say it or admit it at the end of the
day it's the same idea where life has no
real actual value and in fact according
to the pro-abortion position our value
whatever value we have and I'm sure
anti-natal list would say the same thing
whatever value we have rests on or
depends on how useful our lives are to
those around us and that's why
say well you know an unborn child fetus
has no value because he's he's dependent
entirely on his mother for survival and
then once you're at the womb you're not
as dependent although you're still
dependent for a very long time and then
you start introducing things like
euthanasia at the end of life and what
you've got as we kind of whittle away
from both ends of the spectrum where we
say well very early on in life you're
way too dependent you're no use to
anybody so you have no value then then
at towards the end of your life it's the
same idea so you have no value might as
well just put you down put you out of
your misery like an old dog and what
we're doing is we're whittling away and
we're making we're making the value of
human life not only not inherent but in
fact contingent upon things like
self-sufficiency your usefulness to the
people around you that sort of thing
that's that's what and that's how
anti-natal let's look at it so when the
Guardian says this is a growing movement
and it's becoming more mainstream I
would totally agree in fact I would
argue that it's been mainstream for
decades now it's just that now people
are being more explicit about it okay
let's let's say I've had this in the
queue all week to talk about the Daily
Mail as an article it says the Irish Man
you know the movie the Irishman Martin
Scorsese me
the Irishman viewers are left baffled as
lead actress Anna Paquin speaks only six
words in her entire 10-minute air time
during three and a half hour film I
guess some feminists are trying to make
this into a sexist thing they're saying
Anna Paquin lead actress in the film
doesn't talk enough which first of all
if you're in the film for 10 minutes
there's a three and a half hour film
you're not a lead actress so that's the
first thing second it's it's a film with
Robert De Niro Al Pacino Joe Pesci
pretty much every legend that is still
alive that has been in a mob movie any
time in the last 50 years is in this
movie so I don't think anyone is going
to a three-and-a-half-hour Martin
Scorsese movie with the neuro Pesci and
Pacino wanting to hear Anna pack
talk more I don't think anyone's gonna
walk away there's no way you could walk
away from that film well after having
having watch it for 3.5 hours saying you
know it was pretty good but I just wish
I heard more from Anna Paquin that's
really why I was here just completely
desperate to find sexism whatever they
can but Anna Paquin by the way for her
credit has just dismissed all this and
said it's ridiculous and she was very
happy to just be in the film because I
could imagine that if you're an actor a
sword actor and Martin Scorsese comes to
you and says hey do you want to be in my
movie with Robert De Niro and Al Pacino
and Joe Pesci you're gonna say yes I
know give me two words and I'll be there
alright finally let's go to emails Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com this is from rachel says hi
Matt coming from Kansas I can assure you
that the Midwest is not responsible for
the abomination that is the Monte Cristo
sandwich like you I had been spared of
knowledge of this offense of the taste
buds for most of my life this so-called
dish darkened my world when I started
dating my now husband who comes from the
West Coast his utter wrongness
concerning Montecristos palatability is
one thing I must overlook to keep our
marriage working as for the Midwest our
culinary shame consists of pairing chili
with cinnamon rolls pairing chili with
cinnamon rolls it is a combination I
find bizarre and frankly as unpleasant
as a Monte Cristo in my opinion sweet
tastes do not work with meat or cheese
I'm happy we're able to salvage our meal
of chick-fil-a the best fast food out
there chili and cinnamon rolls now I
know what they do in Ohio Cincinnati
where they put chili on spaghetti and
that's that's bad enough because chili
is not a pasta sauce okay it's its own
dish if you're having chili that you
think could be improved with spaghetti
then you know that is that's just bad
chili it's the same
thing I say about french fries and
ketchup by the way if your french fries
need ketchup what does that means that
the french fries are not cooked well
they're not seasoned well if you've got
well-seasoned well-cooked french fries
you're not gonna Sully them with ketchup
which is for children by the way no
self-respecting adult should ever use
ketchup in any in any circumstance once
you get over the age of 13 ketchup
should be illegal speaking of things
that should be illegal chili and
cinnamon rolls where is this happening
is this all across the Midwest is it in
one particular state where who is doing
this who's responsible who started this
you can't just do that you you you don't
have the right to do whatever you want
with chili and I'm really tired of this
chili is a specific thing and it should
be respected there is nothing in the
Constitution that gives you the right to
do whatever you want with chili to
deface it and desecrate it and blaspheme
it and whatever way you want it's not
covered in the First Amendment nothing
gives you the right that is disgraceful
I mean do when you say parent do they
combine it how does the pairing work I
know there are people who put cinnamon
in their chili so another thing they do
and you know why the Midwest listen I
don't mean to dump on the Midwest again
I and I've been harsh on Ohio today
especially with the Browns and bangles
but I mean there are and I like the
Midwest okay let me just say that I've
been the Midwest much other people
they're very friendly all the
stereotypes about people the Midwest are
the nicest people the world that's
that's been my experience they're the
people there are ridiculously nice so
much so that as a cynical person from
the East Coast when I go to the Midwest
I almost get suspicious when they're
when they're so friendly when someone
walks up to me a stranger and they're so
nice I immediately think like what's
your angle what are you getting at here
why are you being so nice what do you
want from me that's what you get from
living on the East Coast so a lot of
nice things to be said about it but when
it comes to the food you just there's
there's got to be an intervention I
think other the other regions of the
country need to sit the Midwest down and
say
you know listen there are some great
things about you we don't deny that but
when it comes to the food
you're really getting out of hand
especially with chili all right let's go
to Joel says for Matt Aloha from the
sandwich Isles also known as Hawaii
question for you New York is recognizing
31 genders I hear you and the other
daily wire show host talk all the time
about gender instead of sex is that
giving a leftist validation for the
corruption of the language the leftists
have taken the word sex and are making
people say gender when they really mean
sex heck over here in Honolulu in front
of the Hawaii State Library we have a
statue of former Hawaii representative
Patsy Mink one of the few responsible
for authoring title 9 which talks about
sex discrimination but it has been
corrupted on the Statue base to say
gender discrimination
I don't remember law being passed saying
that gender and sex are the same thing
although the leftists are pushing it
that way going forward might it be
better to use the correct term of sex
instead of using gender and Rob the
leftist of their attempted language
heist yeah I agree with you I I kind of
used the it's sort of a lazy thing I use
the terms interchangeably because they
they really do mean the same thing the
distinction between sex and gender is
Britain is absurd and arbitrary really
gender originally is is a grammatical
concept so language you know you could
have gendered language and words with
certain but but like in in Spanish you
know you have masculine there's a lot of
masculine and feminine words and so on
so that's that's where gender originally
applied taking it and saying that a
person has a gender is a pretty new
thing and I agree that it's probably
better if we go back to just talking
about sex so that that's something that
sometimes I use it because just to
distinguish what I'm talking about
because it might be confusing otherwise
so for instance if I'm talking about the
left's theory of gender or their assault
on gender I say gender instead of sex
because if I said sex you might think
that I'm in intercourse and something
like that so I that's where I use it
just to distinguish it in that way but
um
I agree that this is listen the left has
run the culture for so long and they
have done so much to corrupt our
language that even people who are aware
of it and opposed to it we can sometimes
fall into using the language that
they've assigned us to use and so that's
why we have to be more discerning and
thoughtful in the way that we speak
making sure that we're not accidentally
surrendering the argument just with the
language we choose to use when we talk
about it
so I agree with you there
I think we'll actually wrap it up there
okay this is one more food thing from
Jason says I was a huge fan until today
you've crossed Midwestern lines with
your negative cheese talk I checked the
Bible and I quote thou shalt eat copious
amounts of cheese I was dedicated
dedicated soldier to your future
dictatorship and now I will lead the
rebellion against you for the line you
have crossed said in Greta Thune Berg
voice how dare you how dare you Jason
look I I and I got a lot of stuff emails
on the cheese thing I'm not against
cheese I am a cheese proponent okay
you're not you're not gonna fire very
many people who are bigger fans of
cheese than me but I think the cheese in
know is sort of like peanut butter and
cheese is a lot better than peanut
butter don't get me wrong peanut butter
is overrated but I only compare them
because they are both used I think too
often as a culinary crutch they are
introduced into dishes where they don't
belong and they tend to take over and
they're very bossy and they want to make
it all about them and so that's my thing
with with cheese cheese has every right
to be as confident as it is because it
is delicious but sometimes you introduce
it into a dish and all of a sudden it's
all about the cheese same thing with
peanut butter
you know people put peanut butter and
you know all kinds of desserts and
cookies and you know things put a little
you know peanut butter and chocolate
chip cookies and they mix it together
and it's like I just want the chocolate
cookie now you've made it all about the
stupid peanut butter so that's my only
point cheese is that we you don't and
with the Monte Cristo thing
you've got french toast confectioner
sugar then you put cheese in there you
didn't I mean take the take the actually
with the Monte Cristo take the cheese
out and then the meat just put it off to
the side maybe fry it and put it to the
side now you've got yourself a good
breakfast dish it's good to go
you throw the cheese on top and it's
it's just confusing and gross but thanks
for the email and thank you for
everybody for watching hope you guys
have a great weekend Godspeed the Matt
Walsh show is produced by Sean Hampton
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Sterling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler
audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there